halo has always been about playing with
your old friends while making new ones
with the launch of halo 5 guardians
you'll be able to find or join
like-minded halo players in brand new
ways thanks to the introduction of
spartan companies spartan companies are
groups you can create or join based on
the types of players you want to play
with whether you're looking for a
regular team for warzone matches or want
to join a squad of super competitive
players for arena
finding the perfect Spartan company is
easy you can browse existing groups
search for group types or create your
own choose wisely as you can only be a
member of one Spartan company at a time
a Spartan company gives up to 100
members access to private forums where
they can plan schedules or discuss
strategies they can also see the service
records of fellow members and check
their armor setups and recent
multiplayer stat each Spartan company
will have its own look thanks to
customizable emblems banners
descriptions and mottos it's up to you
to define what your group is about and
to celebrate the launch of Spartan
companies players who join or create one
will get a free req pack once their
company gains for members and becomes
active and check this out if you open
your reckon he low Waypoint calm your
new cards will be waiting for you when
you boot up halo 5 Guardians you can
also check out your existing card
collections and preview new customizable
options for your Spartan but it doesn't
stop there with Waypoint spartan
customized experience you'll be able to
equip your new armors weapon skins
helmets and visors anywhere and they'll
be ready to go the next time you play
you can also drool over tons of other
customization options so you know what
to unlock next and there's still more to
come on October 26 we'll be opening up
our brand new Halo 5 stat page and rec
page so you can view your soon to be
amazing stats and Rec card collection so
what are you waiting for head over to
Halo Waypoint comm slash spartan
companies and rally your group claim
your free req pack and plan your attack
we'll see you on the battlefield when
halo 5 Guardians releases on October
27th
you